we are dedicating our show next
Wednesday a week from today to a live
special focusing on mental health we're
calling it stop the stigma we want to
take the shame and the blame out of
discussing mental illness diagnosis the
hour will feature queer eyes star and
mental health advocate that's cara mo
brown our special will also highlight
scientific advancements in treatment
technology and over the next week
celebrities and people from all over the
country will share their stories on our
digital platforms after three combat
tours I've learned not all wounds are
physical I have anxiety and depression
and it does not define me I feel like if
I can open up and share what I've been
through maybe somebody else who's kind
of going through something similar can
have some contacts if I could do
anything would be for my brothers and
sisters I have those wounds inside to
seek the help they need once you talk
about it other people will become more
comfortable talking about their personal
journeys also you can hear more from Lao
and others about stopping the stigma on
CBS this morning social media platform
it's all about taking shame and blame
out of mental illness diagnosis what we
do I am to agree completely important
absolutely and you can see our live
special stop the stigma that's on
October 23rd and of course that's right
here on CBS this morning